the media slashing jobs again as the
trump news cycle fades and the economy
struggles cnn this is from cnn
for years the media industry has been
forced to compete with tech platforms
that are advertising revenue and
consumers time now in addition to the
same pressures publishers will see
increased competition for attention as
the economy opens back up about 130
million people in the u.s and about 500
million globally have been vaccinated
against
covet 19 which means some semblance of
normalcy
uh is on the horizon but this coupled
with the fact that by the administration
doesn't drive a non-stop news cycle like
the predator
podesta's predecessor means that
consumers are starting to spend less
time
on their screens competing with the
user-generated content
is top of mind for austin reef
co-founder morning brew
he said you're competing with basically
every human
on the planet everyone on uh everyone
can create content publishers have to
figure out
what makes you unique why are you going
to open up a morning brew newsletter
versus just go on instagram or go on
twitter
thoughts on this um the media is going
to go after
the low-hanging fruit they think about a
new cycle for that day and they attack
it that's why trump was a gift from god
for them
for four years actually five and a half
years you know when he started his
campaign
they had him that's why i couldn't
understand you know
their their intensity of getting him out
you got what you wish for he's gone
so here's the bottom line and this is
where it's going
they have to find something else now
because they don't have compelling
personalities
namely one interesting personality on
msnbc
or really cnn i mean they have some
names that are out there the don lemons
of the world because they rail on trump
you know who they are but can they carry
a show if they don't have
one enemy or one thing just to rail
against this is going to happen you mark
this down this is 100
here's what's coming the covid threat is
going to be back
and i guarantee you and i promise you
that is what the media is going to hang
their hat on
for the next few weeks you watch for it
i'll tell you two alerts i got today
l.a time la times right and this is
where things are getting better
in la we're about to hit the next tier i
think it's the orange tier
right where they allow 50 occupancy
inside restaurants it's really getting
that's traffic pat i mean there's
traffic jams you're getting caught in
traffic for the first time
right in over a year i look at that
first time you're actually
certain people aren't gonna be able to
go to 160 on the freeway anymore i don't
know whoever these people are
so here's the la times alert today a
life and death
race all right a life and death race
right now that we're in with covid
here's the one from the usa today we're
skating on a knife's edge right now
scientists worry u.s could be headed for
yet another coveted 19 surge
all the evidence is saying the numbers
are going down because they are
hospitalizations deaths all of it it's
going down
it's getting better these people are
evil that keep pushing this on us
this effect that it has on optimistic
people and people that have hope
and people with common sense it's just
demoralizing you've got to ignore some
of this stuff
you've just got to get your news from
vtpose.com because we're not going to go
out there and scare the hell out of you
we're just going to tell you what's
going on but this is serious and this is
where it's going and you're going to
hear it all week i promise you
i mean it is what it is uh you know the
what i can appreciate whether you're a
fan of trump not a fan of trump is that
we're we're beginning
whether it's covid whether it's trump
there's definitely a return to normalcy
in this
um country and we're getting back to
reality not a reality tv
president and whether trump was here for
four years or for eight years it is what
it is
the media would always try to find a new
story i mean you worked in media for a
long time you get it
the stress that was going on in the last
four years for most people i asked
someone the other day i said
can you tell me what joe biden is up to
these days and they were
they're sort of a middle of the ground
person they go honestly i haven't paid
attention the news in like three months
and and i'm like go on you were so
involved in every story
for years you were posting stuff on your
social medias like they're like yeah
i'm over it now so for the average
person out there
just move on with your life bro if the
media if their ratings are down
who cares msnbc had ridiculously high
ratings
now i'm sure fox will spike back up
because they can rail against biden and
msn embassy msnbc will drop and
certain cnn shows and cuomo show won't
have
they'll always find a story to spend
they'll always find the news of the day
i can understand and appreciate why you
think covet will be a story for the next
few weeks but the reality is you know
we've already vaccinated 100 million
people
biden came out there and he said by
may 1st or before may 1st the next few
weeks
uh 90 of americans will be able to be
vaccinated so
i think and i'm knocking on wood here by
this summer i think
there's actually going to be a return to
normalcy in this country and i think
that's what most people want to see
can i make a recommendation i want to
make a recommendation okay and by the
way if you like this recommendation do
me a favor and go on twitter and tweet
it at him
okay if you buy this recommendation and
put hashtag
pbdpodcast okay if this makes sense
i want you to take out your phone and go
tweet this out
with this recommendation and put hashtag
pbdpodcast and i'm going to like
every single one of the posts to get the
attention out there ready
i think if there's ever been a time to
buy a company
today's a great time to buy cnn because
they're getting hammered
and i think the right person who has the
money to buy cnn
and can buy for dirt cheap right now is
a guy named elon musk
i don't think bezos should buy cnn i
think elon musk needs to go by
cnn mr elon musk if you're listening to
this
i highly highly highly
recommend you by cnn you would piss off
half the planet if you bought it
and you would gain so many viewership
because people would be all over it if
your name's behind it
just go do it cut a check he's not gonna
do it
i don't know if he would do it or not
cut a check go by cnn
i think if a koch brother try to buy the
surviving koch brother if they try to
buy they're not going to let them buy
they have the money if they wanted to
buy it
i think if anybody on the right were to
buy they're not going to let them buy it
but elon musk is politically if i were
to say elon musk where he's at i put
elon musk in the middle i think elon
musk is center guy
and i think elon musk could actually
make cnn exciting
and it would be great to have a new
station actually be center
there's things that are far right there
are things that are far left
what about if musk buys cnn can you see
that happen it would be
amazing actually because you know i was
actually going to bring up the point
today you know he's in the news every
single day
is there a point where he's not as
interesting anymore and if he owned this
network
he wouldn't have to worry about anything
on social media being banned at any time
he could get away with anything he
wanted
uh it would be a pretty brilliant move
i'm going to tweet it out right now
crazy idea
i believe elon musk and if you want to
go retweet this
i believe elon musk okay go ahead
adam do you have an opinion on this or
do you have anything to say about this
who is the who's the um
who's leading jeff zucker was his name i
believe he's
stepping down he's the head of cnn i
believe he's stepping down
right now no you're already he knows i
think his exit strategy
is like mid to late 2021 and where's ted
turner in all this these days i know
that's uh
someone you know right right where's ted
turner where does he
turner is pissed off with what cnn
turned into believe it or not you see
how he finishes his books
his book he wasn't happy about the way
cnn ended right
you know if if elon bought cnn at least
you would go into it thinking this is
not going to be political
if jeff bezos buys cnn it is a political
left-wing news organization period
just like the washington post if elon
did it you'd have so many people that
were just interested well and be
entertaining the entertainment factor of
it would be
you know pretty much through the roof
because it would be unpredictable and
everything but yeah it would be nice to
see something where you look at it
and you can't identify what political
leaning they have that would be cool
um i mean cnn do you
where would you put cnn on the on the
curve where
how far left they're the block right
next to msnbc
okay so don lemon chris that guy's very
left
chris palmer's a little bit more towards
the middle a lot no
no he's not towards the middle he's he's
not the middle i said
okay go buy cnn buy it buy it elon
go buy cnn put on a group okay
let's raise the money go by he could
overpay for it
he could do it it's a great time to do
it uh-huh it's a great time to do it
right now
there's your overpaying reference so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye